jackie the binding administration is
preparing to reinstate that trump era
remain new mexico policy after being
ordered by a court to do so for more on
the border we're joined now by
republican congressman from texas a
member of the house appropriations
committee tony gonzalez
congressman before we get into the
border i do want to give you just a
moment an opportunity to to weigh in to
react to this tragic ambush on the three
texas constable deputies one of whom we
know has lost their life this morning
congressman
yeah no my heart goes out to the law
enforcement officers here in texas that
are doing everything they can to keep
our community safe what i'd like to see
from the biden
administration and his speech here
shortly is the the president be crystal
clear that america is behind law
enforcement offers officers and to be
crystal clear that we will apprehend the
people responsible for this and they
will be brought to justice full justice
and we will seek the death penalty for
those that have killed innocent police
officers it needs to be that clean a
speech uh you know this rhetoric of
encouraging anti-law enforcement uh
rhetoric to be spewed by by democrats in
particular is become deadly
such an important point congressman
because as we now turn the conversation
to the border so many of the agents men
and women working around the clock
overwhelmed on the border feel some
loss of confidence with this
administration with the decisions
they've made
now when i have talked to agents they do
tell me that if remaining mexico is
reinstated as the court has ordered the
administration to do so it may help your
thought
yeah i know myself and many of my
republican colleagues have been pushing
to uh to reinstate the trump policies at
work the remain in mexico policy works
it's encouraging to see this
administration start to to go down that
route we have to hold them accountable
and you know i'm not stopping until i
see that policy get reinstated what i
will say is on the border the cartels
are controlling everything and it has
become pure chaos on the surface you're
seeing the migrant situation but
underneath the surface you're seeing
this deadly uh this deadly uh area that
encourages terrorism that encourages uh
uh these cartels that are very
sophisticated they're working with with
uh cryptocurrency they're they are
exploiting our our border at all levels
and all facets it's not just the
migrants that we see on the surface you
wrote an important op-ed in the hill
newspaper this past week about cartels
and cryptocurrency is it your view then
that the cartels are really stronger
than they've ever been and only growing
these cartels are extremely
sophisticated
and they pose a danger far more than
what we've seen on the surface they pose
a danger utilizing these
cryptocurrencies that are essentially
unregulated are a direct attack against
the us dollar this is a battle that the
united the united states is in a battle
with these cartels and the bottom line
is we are losing and it's up to the
biden administration to not only gain
hold of the southern border to protect
innocent uh people that live along the
border but also protect our financial
institutions and other things as these
cartels continue to uh become more
sophisticated you know imagine instead
of coming over with a backpack full of
cash imagine you come over with a thumb
drive filled with a with full of
cryptocurrency
and congressman as we look at live
images from our fox flight team of la
jolla texas part of the ground zero in
the rgv the heaviest areas not far uh
from where you are on the border as well
but i went this past week to panama down
to the country of panama all the way
down to the darien gap jungle the
densest jungle
on earth where we are seeing tens of
thousands
particularly haitian migrants coming
through there the cartel has a virtual
pipeline that runs from south america
all the way across our border and you
were able to speak with the foreign
minister of panama erica moynez
when she came to washington somewhat it
sounds like desperate for some help from
the administration what did she tell you
yeah that's right i met with the foreign
minister a little over two weeks ago and
uh and she was really sounding the alarm
on uh on what is happening there in
panama you know uh one thing is they
they've encountered over eight eight uh
eighty thousand migrants there's more on
the way they've encountered many folks
that are associated with terrorism once
again this is a direct threat to the
united states and these folks don't just
arrive at our southern border it is
happening well in advance uh what we saw
in del rio weeks ago we will see over
and over again unless something happens
i appreciate you going down to the
darien gap and covering it firsthand you
know historically those numbers around 8
000
migrants passed through their year that
number is 10 times as much and only
getting worse this administration has to
act and it has to act now it does indeed
and we're out of time i got to let you
go but i was trying to find out when i
got back last night if anything had
changed on those spending negotiations
on capitol hill just 10 seconds do you
have an insight on where we are
spending is out of control when you're
negotiating from three and a half
trillion to one trillion it's already a
loser all the way around inflation is
continues to spile out of control
congressman tony gonzalez thank you for
taking time have a great rest of your
saturday
thanks